Thanos is the villain of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe there's been a lot of
character work put into the Cinematic
version of Thanos which is especially
impressive considering that most of it
is shown to the audience in Infinity War
a movie that's also juggling story arcs
for dozens of other characters at the
same time through it all he's shown to
have the same quality that all the
greatest villains share he thinks he's
right he's the hero of his own story the
only one who can step up and save the
universe from itself and is willing to
sacrifice whatever he needs to in
pursuit of that goal in the comics
Thanos has been referred to as the
ultimate nihilist but the mcu's version
is the exact opposite he believes very
much in what he's doing which makes him
even more compelling and more dangerous